llegan a méxico en busca de una conexión
con su alma el objetivo escapar de una
realidad mediada por una inflación
generalizada guerras pero también la
degradación del planeta una frágil salud
mental luego de las secuelas de la
pandemia el destino tepoztlán a una hora
de la capital mexicana en donde cientos
de visitantes dejan el caos de las
grandes metrópolis para conectar con los
sonidos de la naturaleza
aquí me encanta la vibra que la gente
está más relajado y si como dice más
espiritual y no toma tantos
preocupaciones sobre el mundo que está
alrededor que vive celebrando el día de
hoy muy cerca de las pirámides mayas de
palenque
visitantes entran a una cámara de sudor
calentada por piedras ardientes buscando
un encuentro interior al sonar de la
pandereta
[Música]
esta práctica prehispánica denominada
temascal es una herencia de los pueblos
originarios
el ritual consiste en un baño de vapor
con hierbas aromáticas y según quienes
lo practican logra despertar niveles del
espíritu y el alma que han estado
dormidos si desde la pandemia llegó
mucha gente a tepoztlán extranjeros que
se vinieron a vivir aquí gente de la
ciudad que salió y se dieron cuenta que
las ciudades van a usted va a bloquear
un poco ahí la energía y aquí está el
aire el agua el viento las montañas los
pájaros que es un momento de regresar a
la naturaleza de cuidar a la naturaleza
pero méxico no sólo atrae a gente en
búsqueda mística el país maya es foco de
turismo que representa el 71 por ciento
del producto interno bruto en 2021 fue
el segundo país con más flujo de
viajeros después de francia según los
datos de la organización mundial del
turismo